do you see the internet as being both
but it is a is that more of a hopeful
direction or can you see it also
exacerbating the problem no einen gets
more of a hopeful direction my my the
happy story I'd like to tell myself
about the Internet is someone with some
tiny village up in Ontario or in Kenya
or Brazil somewhere who gets next to the
internet and realizes I can get out of
this preposterous scene by simply if I'm
ambitious if I just unleash my own
ambition and the educational power of
this and I can go to the large city and
conquer go to the capital and export
myself to somewhere else and I assume
this is happen because you know you need
him the third-world incredibly ambitious
people who only by their circumstance
that are kind of fun
well if you rearranged their their
circumstance so if they want a degree in
electrical engineering all they have to
do is be online night after night after
night
that's pretty excited how do you see
that changing the kind of the cultural
matrix or the emerging global culture
well hopefully it gives it a more
international flavor and people realize
that there isn't news words like me kind
of a natural elite native intelligence
or something yeah but in fact there is I
mean smart people would be a fine thing
to put them in charge for the water
let's see if that does any good they're
taking charge where the money is but
that's not a very deep value what if
they took charge where the power and the
actual
well the morphogen etta content what's
coming from the design proceeds this is
where people who you know Mao said or
somebody said to get rich is glorious
I'd say to get rich is modestly affirm
humble is something like there's no sin
in getting rich as long as what you're
doing is not you know making people into
lampshades or something like that it's
better than a collectivist goal of some
sort it seems to me
how you feel about that
junction of media manipulation money and
celebrity it's so dominant no well you
have to have something to sin no you
have to have something people actually
want I mean if you're selling the
Rolling Stones or you're selling Charles
Manson when you're selling something
like that you might get somewhere but
inherently you can't sell that which is
eternal because turns against it so and
that's what defeated fascism nobody
wanted it it was ugly ultimate it's
probably what defeated socialism
cinderblock housing facilities rhetoric
I don't know social planning ran off the
cliff in between to a century maybe
because there were too many people or
too much money or not enough money that
something defeated all these utopian
visions of how people might live that's
what I'm hoping it doesn't happen in the
next 25 years look at what does it do
that some lack of resource or vision
doesn't reveal that we can't give enough
people a bearable life so we have to
live forward into an age of revolution
social turmoil and and struggle for
resources doesn't have to be this way
you see going the direction toward that
kind of a struggle that's my concern
that people and institutions not respond
to me need to and then what you get is a
have have-nots situation I mean you
wouldn't want the first half of the 21st
century to look like the first half of
the 20th century equivalent of a
Bolshevik dialogue the equivalent of
whatever soft leftism turned out to me
and be because it turned out to mean be
not bloody much as far as I can tell
there's a lot of labor I'm asked some
amelioration of some people's you know
dilemma in the system but the world is
far richer than it appears to be and
that wealth is not being it's not
trickling down or slow down or making
nearly as many people's lives as good as
it could so far it doesn't seem to have
gotten out at hand I mean most people if
you give them a lot of money they buy
second homes and collect art well this
is not exactly like hunting down serves
it with your shotgun
entrepreneurial capitalists this is what
they're doing they're building vast
wealth downstream for their children
it's probably you know sort of like the
invention of very large and stable
sailing vessels whenever that happened
to under two hundred and fifty years ago
we're suddenly a whole bunch of people
realized you know only need is some
money not too much money if we buy a
ship and send it out to Indonesian and
bring back a load of nutmeg our
children's children's children will
never work again
one load of this ship and and they have
to work of course and then they get a
certain lifestyle and a certain amount
of social respect down with it but I
think what they leaving it out of it is
the satisfaction of knowing that they've
secured for their heirs comfortable
existence until the ninth generation or
something
well it's interesting about that because
that ties in with the genetics if you if
you buy into some evolutionary
psychology certainly at this stage of
the game one of the forms that that
would take is not merely like the logic
that guides you how you choose a mate
and the fact that your status and money
might you know if you're a male bring
you a foxy or younger babe then the the
schmoes you know shoveling [ __ ] that one
form that that would take would of
course be to maintain your you're a
genetic line and as you know know
greatest situation as possible well uh
now people understand that this is what
your genetic line is about that to cope
or to be in that Darwinian position of
competition in this society means to
have money and not a little not
sufficient but plenty so that when you
mean to arrive at the
by rolls-royce limousines or whatever
that it's not an issue this all comes
down but do you see that there's also
kind of madness to that to that
yeah I'm not motivated I mean as you see
I need a place to keep some books dry
having achieved that my motivation falls
to pieces and it's alright what else do
we need to keep dry some firewood ok a
truck ok that's about as far as I can go
you know the way that technology that
the internet would allow you to build a
different kind of career because you
don't like traveling and what were you
working what are you working towards
well essentially the Philosopher's Stone
without any dramas in other words
everything I require of the alchemical
quintessence the Internet provides
except physicality which I didn't
require so that's how I'm an Edith and I
said to you yesterday or the day before
that at times these technological
developments have taken place that
seemed to me designed uniquely for my
own satisfaction
Sputnik couldn't have worked better for
me acid rock and roll small computers
large computers the Internet
so in my internal story about what's
supposed to happen everything is
happening right on time right on
schedule
I mean this is the thing that if you
believe knowledge is power which I
certainly then the Internet is the
dispensation the Angels have land the
aliens had found fur of their
banner on this planet and now let's see
if information can be liberated that's
why I don't want to do something stupid
like die and miss the whole unfoldment
of this proposition that knowledge is
power information will liberate and it
will be settled in the next 10 or 15
years either they'll get a handle on it
whoever they are whatever a handle means
or it will slip from their control and
it will be clear that some kind of
dialogue is now going on between
individual human beings and the sum
total of human knowledge and that
nothing can stop it some kind of
Renaissance some kind of total new
relationship to knowledge and
possibility is put in place
[Music]
[Music]